Speaker 1: So we had this long period
of basically complete silence on the
congressman Matt Gates investigation and
possible forthcoming charges. Then last
week we learned that Matt Gates ex-girlfriend
had testified before a grand jury. And now
things are moving significantly more quickly.
We have learned that Matt Gates ex-girlfriend
has been granted immunity in the sex trafficking
probe investigating the congressman, so let's
kind of back it up and reset the
entire thing. I believe it was in
March of 2021. I remember where where
I was, we were on break. That week,
news broke that Matt Gates was being investigated
for a number of possible crimes. Matt Gates is
the radical Trumpian Republican congressman
from Florida. He's an absolutely horrible
extremist in every sense of the word and in every
sense of the of of every aspect of him falls under
that category. The charges that were being looked
at and remember, he has not been charged with
anything yet. That's sort of the whole point of
this. It includes charges stemming from possible
actions involving paying people for money and the
transportation of underage women between states,
which would make it a sex trafficking case.
And then, as we expected, charges any day.
Basically, nothing happened. He did lawyer up
hiring some of the best sex crime lawyers in
the country, but nothing happened, and many of
you started to email me asking What's going on
with that? Is the story dead? And of course,
I don't know. Last week we learned that Matt
Gaetz ex-girlfriend testified before a grand jury.
And this was one of the first recent signals that
this thing is not only still going on, but could
be getting very serious. And now we have learned
that Matt Gates' ex-girlfriend has been granted
immunity in the sex trafficking probe. Now
there are a number of different takeaways from
this, which we're going to talk about, but as CBS
News reports. Prosecutors granted immunity to an
ex-girlfriend of Representative Matt Gaetz before
she testified last week in front of a federal
grand jury. Gates has been under investigation
to determine if he violated sex trafficking
laws and obstructed justice in that probe.
Gates has previously denied all wrongdoing and
has said that he has never paid for sex nor
had sex with an underage girl. The woman, who CBS
News is not naming, testified last Wednesday. She
is viewed as a potential key witness, according
to two sources. One of the sources said she has
information related to the investigation of both
the sex trafficking and obstruction allegations.
CBS News legal analyst Rikki Kleiman says quote
This may be a willing participant who has a
smart lawyer who sought an immunity deal from the
government. The government does not give immunity
blindly so they know what they are getting in
exchange. Also, the government or in general,
people typically don't ask for immunity unless
they were involved in wrongdoing in some way.
And the hypothetical that's being laid out is that
in Florida, failure to report child abuse is a
crime. And this is all speculative. But what we're
what is being kind of discussed is if part of her
testimony is that she knew of underage victims is
what they are legally of Matt Gaetz and she didn't
report them. She could theoretically be liable for
that because of Florida law, because in Florida,
everybody's considered a mandatory, a mandated
reporter. If she knew about that shoot, she should
have reported it. And so the most kind of benign
interpretation of the immunity thing would be,
that's what it's about. She knew about
it, and she's only now talking about it,
and she could be liable. Obviously, it could be
far worse than that in terms of the involvement
of Matt Gaetz, ex-girlfriend. We just don't know
at this point in time. But that is what what's
being speculated. So this is not only still going
on, but it is very, very serious. Isabel Kershner,
who's one of these top sex crime defense lawyers,
an attorney for Gates, said the CBS quote, We have
seen no credible basis for a charge against Gates.
We remain steadfast in our commitment to challenge
any allegations with the facts and law. A source
told CBS that as part of an obstruction probe,
investigators are looking into whether Gates
had a phone call with the ex-girlfriend
and another woman who was already a witness
in the federal investigation. Sources told
CBS that the ex-girlfriend and the other woman
traveled to the Bahamas with Gates in 2018,
along with a third woman with whom Gates was
in a sexual relationship. That third woman was
18. But investigators are looking into whether she
was 17 when the sexual relationship. Ship began,
which would be very bad for Matt Gates.
Investigators are also trying to determine
if any of the women were paid and were illegally
trafficked across state and international lines
for the purpose of sex with the congressman. You
know, sort of like common sense suggests to us
that Matt Gates shouldn't be such a compelling
person for women to be with that if he's traveling
to the Bahamas with three women, one of
them was probably compensated to do it.
It is, you know, we think about it and we go,
Well, it's tough to imagine if you're the third
woman going to the Bahamas with Matt Gates
on some kind of sex trip that you're doing it
willingly, but you have to remember 300 million
people in this country. Matt Gates in some, some
very general sense, seeing as a guy, you know,
with power and access to power and at the time had
a relationship with Donald Trump and whatever. We
shouldn't write off the possibility that someone
might have done this without getting paid. But
obviously, when you read about it, it's sort of
like Matt Gates, what on earth is going on here?
It is increasingly looking like there is going
to be a legal problem for Matt Gates coming here.
And the latest is immunity for the ex-girlfriend